bonsoir philippe besset merci d'être
avec nous alors les médecins
généralistes qui ont commencé à
administrer le vaccin sera zeneca dans
leur cabinet depuis le 25 février 7
auprès de vous les formations qu'ils se
fournissent en vexin comment ça se passe
pour le moment les dépeint doit venir
dans l'eau filtrée ferrante et est donc
choisir une officine et a fait un
appariement entre nous et ensuite nous à
nous commandons tous les mercredis les
deux de vaccins qu'ils nous demandent en
faible quantité était une seule un seul
flacon pour 10 de 10 doses de 4 mg
dernière ils peuvent aller jusqu'à deux
flacons pour la pourpre la semaine
prochaine pour cette voie là et ensuite
ils doivent recruter dans leur
patientèle
dix personnes ont ils montent entre 50
34 ans avec d'écomobilité alors sa santé
complet oui et c'est ce que j'allais
dire ça ressemble un petit peu à la
loterie parce que déjà vous comment vous
répartissez ça entre les médecins
généralistes sur quels critères des
critères objectifs 5 par médecin je sais
pas ce qu'ils viennent ceux qui viennent
que qui choisit de la formation et ils
ont droit à une inflation à 1,5 contre
heures par semaine ça c'est combien de
télé viva qui lui est fait pour cette
semaine ils auront droit à trois plaques
ont alors mais oui
pardonnez moi en général ils vous
demandent davantage non non parce que la
problématique c'est vraiment de trouver
et de convaincre les patients qui ont
des pathologies chroniques de venir se
vacciner et en même temps il faut les
regrouper en amphi l'heure ça veut dire
aujourd'hui qui a beaucoup quand même de
scepticisme vous nous dites ça vous dit
voilà finalement il n'en demande pas
plus
c'est l'objectif est plutôt de
convaincre les patients de se faire
vacciner ça veut dire qu'ils ont des
problèmes à convaincre c'est dû à quoi
non c'est un problème d'organisation
normalement le bon circuit fait que les
patients demande va te faire vacciner et
nous ouvrons un carnet et nous ouvrons
des plages de fascination là on demande
aux médecins d'aller convaincre les
patients testés complexe n'est pas
inquiet si fluide dans ce qu'ils font
maintenant c'est changer le circuit
d'une part autorisé l'ensemble de la
plage d'âge 50 pendant à 60 à 75 ans de
se faire vacciner nous priorisons bien
sûr les gens qui ont des cobras vous
douté mais ça n'empêche pas les autres
se vacciner et il faut se faire vacciner
à la fois chez les médecins et à la
pharmacie
donc c'est parce que nous attendons dans
les jours à venir est-ce qu'il ya plus
de mal à convaincre les passants de se
faire vacciner avec l'astra zeneca qui
avait pas une très bonne presse au
départ on s'en souvient écoutez je pense
que c'est vraiment pas le souci le
problème vraiment et c'est d'arriver à
dire aux gens de téléphoner pour
demander une vaccination
ce n'est pas de confier aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qu'il faut pas qu'il faut
tondre alors en tout cas la strazeele et
car on vient de l'apprendre ce soir par
la bouche d'olivier ferrand et tendu où
65 75 ans avec commandité en france
étendue également ou plus de 65 ans
n'était pas le choix de départ de des
autorités on s'en souvient
les explications selon vous elle s'est
rendue à quoi finalement on a fait des
études on s'est rendu compte qu'il était
efficace ou bon bah il ya de la pénurie
donc ça pousse un petit peu à étendre
des autorisations de manière plus large
plage non non non en fait l'étude
initiale était fait sur un très petit
nombre de patients et c'est pour ça que
les il avait été retardé la vaccination
pour les 65 ans et en angleterre depuis
le mois de janvier il y à des millions
de patients de plus de 65 ans qui ont
été vaccinés est donc maintenant mons et
qui que ce vaccin est efficace que c'est
un bon vaccin et que donc avec un peu de
retard
l'angleterre la france et l'allemagne
demain vont autoriser la récitation plus
et donc les médecins généralistes un
québec sinon la vie depuis le 25 février
à caen l'autorisation pour les
pharmaciens de vacciner bah écoute et
j'en suis à faire des conjectures je le
parie pour la semaine prochaine dont je
vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine on verra si j'ai raison à vous
le pas sur une base sur la base de la
conférence de presse que la haute
autorité de santé qui a lieu demain et
des travaux qui ont été portées à ma
connaissance des commissions techniques
qui qui préconise cette vaccination
parlée par les pharmaciens ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup que le collège de
l'autorité santé d'île autre chose que
ce qu'on dit les experts des commissions
techniques donc là la haute autorité
effective demain matin et le mais le
gouvernement devrait suivre le ministre
là on peut dire mot couvert à 18 heures
on sait que ça sera plus simple pour
vous organiser que chez les médecins
généralistes avec d'autres contraintes
peut-être mais un peu plus simple ce
sera un petit peu plus un bruit
d'abord parce que la pharmacie c'est le
lieu
des soins non programmés donc c'est le
lieu où les patients ça valait pour
demander quelque chose sans forcément
avoir besoin de deux rendez vous avec un
peu moins de ré plus de facilité donc je
crois que ce sera plus facile pour les
gens et de toute façon c'est un travail
d'équipé
donc il faudra qu'on est tous parce que
on a quand même 65 millions français à
vacciner deux fois
donc ça fait 130 millions de
vaccinations à faire il faut beaucoup de
gens effectivement et du temps merci
philippe abc d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france président de la
fédération des syndicats pharmaceutiques
de france